meet our next daredevil Jason pullin
from California who transformed his
motorcycle into a motor wheel
I think Jason is quite a creative guy
this is the first flip bike I've ever
seen really impressive that it's just
one single piece of metal and he's able
to roll over and over and over and not
off to the side so how did Jason pullin
pull off this motorized jaunt across the
parking lot when Jason speeds up he gets
a lot of momentum and then he slams on
the brake which stopped the front wheel
and the back wheel keeps going so that
it acts as a hinge and that produces an
acceleration to moving in a circle now
as long as that exceed the acceleration
due to gravity is going to keep rolling
the minimum speed that he needs to be
rolling to achieve this it is around 10
miles per hour
or 16 kilometers per hour so he's got
the speed but what keeps the wheelie
from being wonky the machine that
Jason's using is essentially a giant
wheel and if it tilts off to one side
through a fraction of a second the top
of the bike wheel is moving in that
direction
sort of right however a fraction of a
second later it's now at the bottom and
it's still moving to the right this will
produce a force to write the wheel
making it upright again and keeping it
on this lovely pafter you can see
yes it's definitely physics in action
Jason seems delighted with his science
experiment no matter how well you plan
something out things can always go wrong
and you can see he's just so happy that
this has worked